for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university calm thank you and enjoy
next up the amino acids that are
degraded to acetyl co a how many amino
acids have their carbon skeleton
degraded directly to a CO CO a there are
seven in this case so we got tryptophan
one lysine two phenylalanine three
tyrosine for leucine five isoleucine six
and threonine seven cool let's get rid
of all those check marks alright so
let's start up here at the top left with
tryptophan and also by the way it should
go without saying but try to keep track
of the carbons in the way they're
colored it'll help you a lot and it'll
be a lot for me to keep saying back and
forth but uh if I just just try to keep
track of the colors for instance like
with tryptophan here we're gonna cut it
as we saw in the previous video crypto
fan gets cut sort of right here and that
top portion ends up like we said in the
previous video in alanine right those
three blue carbons end up there and that
alanine can give rise to pyruvate as we
saw previously with this bottom portion
we said goes elsewhere and a lot of us
going to go to a CO CO a so there are 11
carbons total here in tryptophan three
of them left in alanine so we've got
eight left two of them leave as carbon
dioxides so then we have six left and
four of them are these orange ones here
those four end up here and the other two
the other two are going to end up here
and here so of these four carbons that
are not colored here this this one this
one this one in this one two of them
leave as the
carbon dioxide so two of them would be
yellow one of them would be pink which
would end up right here is this carboxyl
group and one of them is purple that
will end up as this carboxyl group in
this molecule here alpha keep keto
adipate which is an alpha keto acid okay
we can also get that alpha keto adipate
from lysine so up here we got lysine
that's got six carbons those six carbons
are going to end up here in alpha keto
adipate but before we can get that we
have to remove these amino groups and
those two amino groups is one there and
there's one there so those are going to
be removed in two transamination
reactions right so two alpha
ketoglutarate SAR gonna become two
glutamates by getting these amino groups
there's also some redox reactions in
there and we'll eventually get alpha
keto out of eight alpha keto adipate
we're gonna add coenzyme a and that'll
be an oxidation of this alpha keto out
of paid to glue to ryuko a and we'll
lose this top carbon up here this purple
one the purple carboxyl group we're
gonna lose that here so we go from
having six carbons to five carbons in
this glue tier okole because we added
this coenzyme a right there okay now
that gluts hiroko a is going to be
turned into acetyl coa basically by
removing this at least that's the short
short way to think about it and it's
gonna be a three-step sort of situation
and these three steps are similar to
beta oxidation beta oxidations first
three steps are an oxidation a hydration
and another oxidation here it's pretty
much the same except we have an
oxidative decarboxylation in the first
step and then we have a hydration and an
oxidation hydration oxidation and we end
up getting Osito Osito Koh a bi after
losing this carbon here this carboxyl
group has a carbon dioxide and so we get
this acetyl CoA
by the way we should be paying attention
to the idea that as we do
all this stuff we're getting you know
these reduced electron carriers fadh2
and ADH nadh so on and so forth so pay
attention to that because that could be
used for energy of course
okay so let's eat OSE doko a right here
we can also get this if we start from
back up here to the top right okay so up
here we've got phenylalanine we'll start
with phenylalanine up here again keep
paying attention to the the way the
carbons adjust the atoms are colored and
and and whatnot so we're gonna turn
phenylalanine to tyrosine and the only
difference to the two molecules it's
what's going on right here at this
carbon there is it an O H there and now
there is so in phonology there's no o H
to get that o H we have the
phenylalanine hydroxylase reaction and
this enzyme is actually of particular
importance and we'll see that actually
in the next video and this reaction and
it isn't it just this enzyme being
important this cofactor here the
tetrahydrobiopterin is important in that
reaction as well okay so we're know for
phenylalanine nine carbons the tyrosine
with still with nine carbons just with
this all weights group after that
phenylalanine hydroxylase reaction and
then with this tyrosine
four of the carbons these four blue ones
will come off as a fumarate so those two
amino acids phenylalanine and tyrosine
both give rise to fumarate here okay one
of those key products and as far as the
other five carbons out of these this
nine four of them these four orange ones
end up in acetoacetate and one of them
that carboxyl group carving up there
will leave as a carbon dioxide and we
lost the amino group in a transamination
reaction here
to get acetyl acetate now we can also
get that acetoacetate from leucine so
these four orange carbons here three of
them come from right here on leucine
okay and in going from loosing to
acetoacetate we have to get rid of the
amino group in a transamination reaction
here
okay we're also going to lose this
carboxyl group as a carbon dioxide there
okay so we'll go from having these six
carbons and we'll lose one to have five
left over and we're going to add one
here so it would be six total and four
of them make their way to acetyl acetate
so three of the four orange carbons came
from right here okay the fourth one
comes from a car box covered dioxide
okay so we get those four carbons there
what happened to these two yellow
carbons well in those those two yellow
carbons they get a coenzyme a attached
to them
and they are going to give acetyl co a
okay
now the yellow carbons that I just
showed end up being orange here but the
reason why I didn't label them as orange
up here the reason why I didn't make
these orange is because those don't end
up here it's these three and this one
that end up here as orange so I made I
made those two they're yellow because I
didn't want it to get confused with this
okay anyway we get this acetyl acetate
and that acetoacetate can get turned
into acetyl co a by basically just
adding a coenzyme a in this beta key
toys will go a transferase reaction to
give a pseudo color sorry Osito acetyl
co a right here all right now that
acetyl co a of course can give a co co a
basically just
leaving that Osito Osito a into two
acetyl COAS I'm not showing the two here
because I'm also showing how other
things can arrive at this acetyl co a
but here going from Osito Osito Osito co
a to acetyl co a that can happen via the
beta key keto a soakaway transferase
enzyme where the co a is coming from
sectional Kawai or we can have a dial a
sakteng on it which isn't the enzyme
form beta oxidation where we just add a
coenzyme a DAC leave it into two
coenzyme a two acetyl co a ok now we can
also get acetyl co a from isoleucine so
i saluted over here we got six carbons
total in going from my solution to
acetyl co a we lose the amino group in a
transamination reaction and we lose this
carboxyl group up here as a carbon
dioxide so we're left with five carbons
these two carbons end up in acetyl co a
and these three yellow ones here end up
in propane Eelco a so propanol co a
we'll see in a later video ends up in
sucks no co a but that's not what we're
talking about here anyway the point is
that these two carbons end up in this
Etobicoke a which is how isoleucine
gives is degraded to acetyl co a and of
course we have some redox reactions they
are giving nadh and fadh2 s now um that
covers almost all of the amino acids
that give rise to acetyl co a the last
one here is threonine and we actually
saw this in the previous video in the
minor pathway threonine is turned into
two amino three keto butyrate in the
three and a dehydrogenase reaction and
that two amino 3 keto butyrate these two
carbons end up in acetyl co a after that
coenzyme a is attached and this portion
of the molecule
ends up being glycine
okay and so we got all those carbons
ending up basically right here and as
you look away and of course that can go
through the TCA cycle give us some
energy all right I hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying